good morning John today is the first day
off and like four weeks univers cope
conspired to prevent me from getting him
full night's sleep and yesterday I
realized that if I did it one more time
I would destroy the entire universe I
would set it to flame and watch it burn
so I slept lucky for you how long tour
with a rock-and-roll band right now
which is really weird I've been to a lot
of shows of my life and I'll be honest
never in my life have I not felt anxious
before a show whether in there's a
performer or just is someone watching
the show the institution of the show
seems to have a lot of cultural
knowledge associated with it and also
kind of seems like just sort of the
things that like very cool people do I
am NOT a very cool person but I always
felt like there's just a lot of stuff I
don't know and I'm not sure if I'm doing
the right things Ethel it almost seems
like part of the coolness of it is
hiding all those do's and dont's from
normal people so that you can know when
they're not cool and that is the thing I
hate so um I chose I've been asking the
audience what is some of the
institutional knowledge of concerts that
you think should be shared with the
world and I've been collecting that
information and now I'm going to dare it
with you number one bring earplugs
because sometimes it is dangerously loud
sometimes it's not but you never know
number two you can go by yourself it's
nice to bring people along with you but
you can also have an amazing time alone
free make sure you have enough charge on
your cell phone to get you through the
night tour you never know how hot it's
gonna be so hydrate and bring layers 5
buy merch on the way in because when
you're leaving it would be a mess in the
line will be a million miles long mix
dance clap sing-along every audience is
different and what happens out there
affects what goes on on the stage 7 if
you want to be at the front get there
early do not push your way to the front
because you were moving past the people
who got there early so that they can be
at the front and that's route 8
as far as I can tell there's no schedule
I don't even know what I'm going on as a
performer it's up to the venue generally
doors will open about an hour before the
show actually starts and the main act
will be on for at least two hours after
the doors open some venues like to leave
like
thirty minutes between every single act
so that people have time to buy more
drinks which is how they make a lot of
their money none of this has anything to
do with the performers I would assume
that you're not going to be going home
until at least three hours after the
doors open maybe more than four I know
wear comfortable shoes said if you ask
you'll probably get an uncle eleven
interact with strangers chances are your
endings up with the same thing since
you're obviously into the same music
people are usually pretty nice chances
are they're as uncomfortable as you are
like I am right now they're deep mosh
pits are surprisingly safe stage-diving
is surprisingly dangerous don't want
anybody jump on your head you don't want
to be the mosh pit just leave the mosh
pit area if you do make sure that your
shoes are untied and your glasses and
now loose items necessary precautions
are taken etcetera well if you feel
unsafe or uncomfortable let the people
around you know or let the venue staff
know and they will help you and finally
number thirteen this was shot it out at
my Portland show and I couldn't hear the
person who shouted it so I asked the
people around that person to shout it at
me simultaneously and the thing that got
shouted at me by dozens of people was
don't worry about looking cool it was a
glorious moment I wish I could start
every day with a group of people
shouting that at me that would be nice
for all of us and it would be wonderful
if we could all get this through our
thick skulls of course we can't and so
we have to continue repeating it to each
other but don't worry about looking cool
do you because you are fantastic
I had the whole audience shouted at me
again and then I had them shouted at
each other because I think that's the
most important advice when it comes to
going to concerts it's not about looking
cool
it's about being excited about something
together with other people who are also
excited about it and it's been really
really really amazingly fantastic to be
part of that for people so thanks to
everyone who's been coming out of the
show has been having a really great time
John I'll see you on Tuesday